absolute jaw-dropper late this afternoon
a report from the New York Times it lays
out that in the spring of 2017 deputy AG
rod Rosenstein suggested secretly
recording President Trump and discussed
invoking the 25th amendment to throw the
president out of office now Rosenstein
as you'd expect is forcefully denying
that this ever happened
separately a Fox News source said to be
in the same room as this conversation is
claiming that Rosen Stein's comments
were just sarcastic
they weren't serious does anyone believe
that tonight Washington Post is also
reporting that but let's take a trip
shall we down Rosen Stein memory lane
now this is the same guy who responded
like this to demands from Congress to
produce documents in that Russia probe
the Department of Justice is not going
to be extorted we're going to do what's
required by the rule of law so
congressional oversight and demands for
accountability and transparency are
extortion that somehow runs counter to
the rule of law
got it rod well his apparent contempt
for oversight and lawmakers doesn't stop
there here he is in front of this house
Judiciary Committee just a few months
ago I am the deputy turned general
United States okay I'm not the person
doing the redacting I'm responsible for
responding to your concerns as I have
did you read the FISA application before
you signed it not going to comment about
any FISA okay so you won't say to this
committee whether or not you even read
the document you signed that authorize
spying on people associated with the
Trump campaign well I love the trailing
off there it's perfect for a Friday
night and let's not forget that Rosa
Stein even threatened to subpoena emails
phone records and other documents from
lawmakers and staff on the house Intel
committee they did that earlier this
year now let's be clear if the New York
Times reporting is accurate the
president tonight should seriously
consider whether rod Rosenstein should
remain on the job
the White
should be devoting every resource it can
to determining the veracity of this
report we just cannot have this plotting
at the highest levels of the Justice
Department against the chief executive
of this executive branch joining us now
for reaction is former Trump campaign
manager Corey Lewandowski Lee Smith from
real clear investigations and former US
Attorney
Kendall coffee let's go right to you Lee
you have been covering rod Rosenstein
for you know I guess a year and a half
now since he initially got this job is
Deputy Attorney General tonight I just
want to play for you this is a short
montage of a variety of pundits claiming
per the Washington Post that this
conversation about wearing a wire
getting other people to wear a wire this
is all just a joke let's watch if the
words were said it seems more likely
they were said and some sort of
sarcastic were exasperated way rather
than as a serious plan to actually wire
up and go in and do this this does not
give any crowd so I really mean this any
grounds at all in terms of any action of
Rosenstein that justifies firing him it
makes sense to me that maybe he could
have made a crack about this Lee yeah I
mean I think it's important to see the
Rosen Singh's
story the story about Rosenstein in The
Times and in the post these are both
part of the declassification issue they
need to be seen in the context of a
house explain that okay we've seen since
Monday when the president asked when the
president said he was going to
declassify documents over the last week
the New York Times
ABC News a number of publications have
had stories blocking trying to block the
declassification they've been sourced to
former and current US officials I see
this as part of the same thing
the time source the time story is
apparently sourced to Andy McCabe he
says he didn't talk he said his people
are saying they didn't talk to the time
son the lawyer statement looks to me
like a non-denial compiled on Twitter I
think what it looks like is is that
McCabe is or someone close to McCabe is
threatening Rosenstein saying hey I've
got a lot of dirty stuff on you as well
if these thing
aren't Declassified you're going down
with me unbeknownst to Andrew McCabe it
appears according to my sources that
sometime between last night and this
morning
rod Rosenstein went in and talked to
President Trump and convinced him to
hold off and declassifying the documents
kick them instead over to the inspector
just gonna do the inspector general how
does that help the president exactly it
does not help the president the purpose
was to delay but it was Rosenstein
apparently who convinced Trump to do it
unbeknownst to unbeknownst to mccabe the
wrath of the wrathful mccabe had no idea
presumably the time story was in the
works for several days the story drops a
couple of hours after after Trump tweets
that the documents are going to go to
the IG and you can imagine Rosenstein
horror mccabe has blown this beautiful
plan i had to get us both in the clear i
think that's what happened Rosenstein
effort to cover up again the post story
appears sourced to him and the idea is
we have to cover this up i was telling a
joke of course i wouldn't do such a
thing
if it's a joke he and corey you can
chime in here he must have a really lame
sense of humor because here's a joke
isn't hey let's wear well--why I'll wear
a wire or someone else one of you can
and then we'll get someone to invoke the
25th amendment maybe I can get sessions
how is that funny
there's no teehee giggle giggle in any
of that Cory I think he's right I think
Lee is right this is all about the
declassification Trump backtrack for
some reason and I think that was a big
gift to Rosenstein because he's worried
about that FISA application and the fact
that exculpatory information was not put
in that FISA application to monitor
Carter page Corey well you're exactly
right and everybody has to remember that
that was the third renewal of the
application of for actual applications
the first application was denied by the
FISA Court Rod Rosen's team signed this
and when the president made the
announcement that was going to
declassify Bruce ores 302s that was
going to reveal that nelly or Bruce's
wife was talking to Christopher steel
that the Justice Department knew about
this and that I'm sure rod Rosenstein at
the Justice Department was aware of what
Bruce was doing because he was
supervisor in some level that all would
have come out very clearly and he was so
afraid that that declassification was
going to expose him for what he is which
is part of the deep state this collusion
would never exist it's been a fake
dossier from the beginning and look
we've done extensive research on this
now we've seen what rod Rosen seems
really about whether it's Rod Rosenstein
he covered up for Peter schrock for Lisa
page for Andy McCabe for Jim Comey he's
also the individual and you remember
this who recommended Bob Muller become
the head of the FBI went and when Jim
Comey was fired and then the next day he
personally appointed Bob Muller's a
special counselor to investigate this
president tonight the president briefly
referenced this issue with the the
secret recording let's watch we have
great people in the Department of
Justice we have great people these are
people I really believe you take a poll
I got to be at 95% but you had some real
bad ones you seen what's happened at the
FBI they're all gone
but there's a lingering stench and we're
gonna get rid of that too candle a
lingering stench your thoughts there who
is he referring to well obviously he's
concerned about rod Rosenstein I think
he should be I don't think we can make
the New York Times the judge and jury of
Rosen Stein's fate but what the
challenges is to find a very accelerated
framework for getting to the bottom of
this and I don't think the president
needs to for example ask the Justice
Department to investigate itself I think
he has the power and perhaps should go
ahead and put together an investigative
mechanism perhaps relying in part on the
White House counsel's office so that
they can get access redacted blacked out
in certain places or not to whatever
these McCabe memos are and at some point
to bring rod Rosenstein into the office
look them in the eye that is the
president has famously done a lot of
hired and fired people looked in the eye
and see if he can get an adequate
explanation for this because if it's
true if the way it's being presented in
the New York Times is true it's
something very
very troubling that can't be continuing
well apparently according to the report
I'm gonna read some of it I think it's
important that I read some of the New
York Times reporting but apparently the
gist of it is a Rosenstein was really
ticked off that even though he wrote
that letter memo justifying the firing
of Comey giving a justification with the
firing of Comey he was mad that then the
president relied on it when he was asked
about it so he both wrote it I guess out
to suggestion the President or through
quested that he was mad that the
president relied on it and that that
just torqued him off to no one this is
their New York Times reporting I want
all three of you to listen to this
Rosenstein raised the idea of wearing a
recording device or wire as he put it to
secretly tape the president when he
visited the White House one participant
asked whether Rosen Stein was serious
and he replied animatedly that he was
now it goes on to say it is not clear
how determined he was about seeing them
through though he did tell McCabe that
he might be able to persuade general
attorney general Jeff sessions in John
Kelly's about the 25th amendment then
Secretary of Homeland Security and now
the White House chief of staff to mount
an effort to invoke the 25th and third
point according to others who described
his comments Rosenstein not only
confirmed that he was serious about the
idea but also followed up by suggesting
that other FBI officials who were
interviewing to be the bureau's director
could also also secretly record Trump
this was around the time of course where
after he fired call me he was looking at
Ray Rosen Stein's name had been raised
for this and a few others including a
former Obama person but he wanted a
coordinates report and there's no humor
in this with it when he says it's humor
it's ridiculous Ari this is the woman's
intuition but it's ridiculous no humor
in this now Lee I want to I want to play
this for you because the Democrats
tonight are saying this is just the
pretext Trump needs to fire Rosenstein
this is what Leon Panetta said tonight
he's got to think very carefully about
the implications of taking action here
because if
if he does this it raises concerns about
the Mahler investigation raises concerns
about the possibility of obstruction
okay
why would it be obstruction of justice
the mother investigation goes on I mean
I think the whole thing has it exactly
opposite him enemies Rosenstein who
appointed him I think the interesting
thing and revelatory thing about these
two stories is is it exposes a lot of
people a lot of wrongdoers at the FBI
and DOJ they're turning on each other
like rats I hope that the President sees
that before he makes any decisions and
I'll say that I think the important
thing the really vital thing is
declassifying these documents so that we
can all understand what the bad guys at
the DOJ and the FBI were doing as these
two articles give some sort of
indication of there's more in those
documents we can be sure of we'd like to
see them and Cori it is true is it not
that the president can reverse his
reversal at any moment now for now
kicking over to the Inspector General
which again has no subpoena power
I mean Horowitz is a good guy but this
is not gonna get us anywhere he can
reverse his decision at any moment
because right now it seems to me that
the Bruce or 302s those are the
interview memos that he wrote the FISA
applications and other text messages are
critical to be released unredacted
except for any sources and methods which
there apparently aren't any but quarry
the president has that ability to do
that he has to override Rosen Stein to
do it
well that's right but you have to
remember Laura when he said he was going
to redact it was only certain pages a
pfizer application so there's no concern
from a national security perspective I
think it was pages 10 through 12 and
then 14 other pages there so it wasn't
the entire application so that's
perfectly fine but you also have to
remember Andrew McCabe has been referred
by the IG for a criminal referral that
referral sitting at the Department of
Justice
my guess is rod Rosenstein is the one
who's deciding whether or not Andrew
McCabe is going to be prosecuted for
lying under oath to the FBI on three
separate occasions particularly when he
was the acting director of the FBI after
Jim Comey was fired so look these guys
ran this tight little cabal that they
never thought anyone was ever going to
get caught between Jim Comey and room
Peter struck Lisa Paige Bruce or you
know rod Rosenstein these guys did
things and then you throw in clapper and
and Brennan and you've got the making of
a story that nobody could actually
believe that these nine or ten
individuals have tried from day one to
take down a duly elected president not
only they're a deep state they're an
enemy of the people
Kendyl your reaction this has just been
such a wild day of news both on
Cavanaugh which we're gonna get to in a
moment and on this story but I don't see
how this continues with this this a
white-hot tension between the President
and the Justice Department not about
even Muller at this point this is just
about the running of the department and
just basic decisions about redacting
documents are not redacting I'm
classifying or declassifying I know it's
related to Muller but I don't see how
it's a it's an it's a sustainable
situation with with Rosenstein and I
know other people would say also with
sessions but with Rosenstein I think
it's a bad bad relationship yeah it's
got to be incredibly uncomfortable and
increasingly less productive for the
Department of Justice but I still think
there needs to be a thoughtful very very
fast inquiry that doesn't have to be
formally structured but the president
needs to get to the bottom of this we
can't rely on newspaper stories in terms
of making judgments about one of the
most powerful positions in the United
States government but on the other hand
precisely because the Deputy Attorney
General's position is so powerful this
needs to be resolved as you say and
resolved quickly
all right gentlemen thank you so much